نعم بالفعل قبل قليل دوت صافرات الانذار
في عدد من البلدات في غلاف غزه تحديدا في
منطقه ناح العوز وهذه تحديدا المنطقه تدوي
فيها بشكل شبه يومي صافرات
انذار بسبب اطلاق الصواريخ من داخل قطاع
غزه باتجاه هذه المناطق ويوم امس كانت قد
دوت ايضا في ساعات المساء وفي ساعات ايضا
متاخره صفارات الانذار اكثر من مره
والمنظومه القبه الحديديه اعترضت عددا من
الصواريخ الاسعاف الاسرائيلي بلغ بانه لم
تكن هناك اصابات او اضرار وان منظومه
الدفاعات الجويه للقبه الحديديه تمكنت من
اعتراض الرشق الصاروخيه التي اطلقت باتجاه
هذه البلدات في ساعات مساء يوم امس وهذا
فقط يشير سهام على ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه
ما زالت قادره على توجيه مثل هذه القضائ
الصاروخيه باتجاه هذه البلدات تحديدا في
منطقه غلاف غزه قبل امس الاول كانت هناك
دفعه وصفت بانها الاكبر منذ الحرب منذ
بدايه هذه الحرب اطلقت باتجاه مدينه
نتيفوت في النقب ال الغربي وربما
اي يعني اثرت كثيرا على الشارع الاسرائيلي
لا سما على القرارات التي كانت قد بدات
تصدر في اسرائيل للتمهيد واعاده عدد من
سكان هذه البلدات سيما وان نتيفوت ايضا
تقع على بعد 20 م من غزه الى الشرق في
منطقه النقب الغربي وهذا ربما عاد وعزز
موقف ال السكان هذه البلدات وتصميمهم على
عدم العوده في هذه المرحله الى البلدات
الحدو الحدوديه على عكس ما يحاول تحديدا
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي ؤف جلنت بالدفع به
من اجل البدء واعاده سكان تحديدا المناطق
التي تبعد من اربعه الى سبعه كيلومترات
نتحدث عن اكثر من 70,000 اسرائيلي تم
اجلائهم من هذه المناطق الحدوديه في غلاف
غزه وهناك خطه حكوميه للبدء باعادته لانها
وفقا للاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه اصبح
ذلك واحد من اهداف هذه الحرب عمليا هو
اعاده السكان الى هنا لكن حاليا هناك
معارضه شديده من قبل السكان طالما هناك
صاف انذار تدوي وطالما كانت هناك قضائ
صاروخيه تطلق من قبل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وهذا ايضا يشير بطبيعه الحال وهو ما يتحدث
به اليوم الخبراء والمحللون العسكريين ان
حتى هذا الهدف الذي يعتبر اقل اهداف هذه
الحرب وهو وقف اطلاق الصواريخ من داخل غزه
الى هذه البلدات الحدوديه ولا نتحدث عن
مناطق ابعد مثل مناطق المركز في تل ابيب
ومحيطها حتى ذلك لم يتحقق ولم يتمكن الجيش
الاسرائيلي من القضاء على قدرات حركات
المقاومه في اطلاق الصواريخ هذا اليوم
ايضا تم الاعلان عن مقتل ضابط اخر خلال
المعارك واصابه ثلاثه تحديدا في معارك
جنوب غزه وهذا فقط يؤكد سهام على ضراوه
المعارك الدائره في مواقع مختلفه نعم
نجوان سمري مراسله الجزيره كنت معنا من
غلاف غزه شكرا لك